hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
long-time listeners will know that one
of my areas of interest is complex
systems the study of complexity the kind
of thing that the santa fe institute
does and was founded to do
and if there is any system we can
imagine that you would characterize as
complex it would be an economy right
economy of a large industrialized
country there are a lot of moving parts
related to each other in different ways
it seems as if a priori
economics and complexity theory would go
hand in hand but in fact when you
actually sit down to do economics just
like when you sit down to do any other
science you look for simplifications
right you look for things you don't need
to pay attention to
simple versions of the problem that you
can really get a lot of insight into and
in economics this takes a lot of
different forms we assume that the
different people in an economy are more
or less rational that they have complete
information that they're more or less
all the same kind of people
and most of all that the economy is
basically in equilibrium right think of
supply and demand given a certain supply
curve and a certain demand curve the
price will adjust to a certain point
relatively rapidly and then you'll be in
equilibrium so complex systems research
is all about things where you cannot
assume that all the parts are the same
you cannot treat things as if they were
in equilibrium you can imagine that
different parts of the system have
different amounts of information and so
forth so this opens the idea that
economics is actually not taking full
advantage of the insights gained from
complex systems research and we should
study something called complexity
economics that's what we're going to
talk about today with w brian arthur
who's one of the founders of this field
now i should say you know brian is not a
quirky outsider he was a professor at
stanford for a long time the youngest
person ever to be given an endowed chair
at stanford but he's one of the founders
of this field of complexity economics
dating back to the time when the santa
fe institute was founded in the 1980s he
invented several of the foundational
puzzles and methods in this field and he
thinks that to this day the economics
profession as a whole hasn't quite taken
on the lessons of complexity theory
we're still largely in a certain
neoclassical paradigm that treats the
world as a much simpler much less
dynamic thing than it really is so this
is a fun conversation both for the
economic insights but also for you know
the way of thinking that you become
imbued with when you start thinking
about the world as a complex system
getting rid of simplifications that
simplify over much
thinking of the different layers of the
world interacting with each other
thinking about the evolution and the
dynamical aspects of the problem as
built-in rather than things that we can
try to ignore right real economies have
crashes and bubbles and you can predict
the probability of different things but
if you just look at the equilibrium
you'll never find that kind of behavior
so it'll be useful for anyone interested
in society economics science or
complexity which i hope is everyone out
there listening to this podcast so let's
go
[Music]
brian arthur welcome to the mindscape
podcast yeah hi so i wanted to start
actually we had neil johnson on the
podcast uh about a year ago i don't know
if you know neil but he's another
complexity person and he told us about
the alpha role problem
but i'm going to presume that maybe you
know people have forgotten what it is
and i think that you're at least one of
if not the originator of the alpha role
problem and it's a nice setup for what
we're going to be talking about here so
why don't you remind us what that is all
about
okay
i usually like to flex a few muscles
before you know right here
anyway um yeah i am the
uh
original
uh
i guess i cooked up the alfa roll
problems sometime in the
in the early nineties
alfa roll is a bar in canyon road in
santa fe
and on
thursday nights they used to have irish
music and i would show up
it's a
pretty cramped place and
so it began to occur to me
um should i go to el faro
this thursday or not
and i realized that a lot of other
people would think that too so if you
start to look at that as a logical
problem
say of a hundred people thinking
independently maybe i'll go to l for all
tonight
but if there's more than let's say 60
there it's going to be awful crowded and
smoky and horrible
um i don't want to go
if i think there'd be less than 60 i
will go
and i realized that posed a kind of
strange logical problem
for forecasting
economics is very fond of forecasting
and we call it expectations
if everybody
had the same forecasters sitting on
their desks say
a little plastic device and
it forecasted that 74 people would go
this thursday then nobody would go
if it said that things 15 will go
everybody would go
so
it was a strange situation
where um
whatever people jointly forecasted would
be negated if if many people think
uh
if everybody thinks many people will go
and nobody will go
if they think few will go everybody will
go so
are automatically negated and it's a
kind of
liars paradox for economics i posed the
problem
i came up with my own solution to it
which was to throw overboard any attempt
to be deductive
that wasn't working very well
there's
you can't really come up with a
a solution that everybody shares
so i began to think and this is with the
inspiration of john holland he wasn't
part of this problem but he certainly
inspired my answer
what if everybody had their own
uh collection of forecasts so i might
have
maybe 15 20 different ways to forecast
and
a guy down the street might have a
similar
number but different forecasts so you
have a whole ecology of forecasts
and
how would that work
each um i could track which forecasting
methods worked well for me
uh think of people doing this on the
stock market which they pretty much
do all the time
i could see what didn't work throw those
overboard
and gradually find what does work
and so i programmed this to see what
would happen
lo and behold
forecasts came out
forecasting methods formed a little
ecology because whether my method is
reasonably accurate or not depends on
everybody else's method that i'm
in there with
and so it was
my strategy or my forecasts
uh trying to survive in a
little ecology or a sea of other
people's forecasts
the whole thing settled down to about 60
there was a lot of
chaotic noise around that
and it was a weird thing
a physicist got this right away and
my good friend at the time pereira bach
took this problem
faxed it to all his physics friends and
suddenly the problem
became famous in physics
economists didn't quite know what to
make of it
they kind of walked around it and looked
at it and said you know
their usual solution was to say
everybody's identical
uh by assumption
let's uh say therefore they have
identical methods for forecasting as i
said that doesn't work in this problem
what does work is an inductive approach
uh i think maybe
these possibilities
for forecasting might work somebody else
might think
other possibilities work
and
the
solution
never quite settles down because as
uh people keep trying these and
different people show up as a result
um
the situation keeps changing so it never
quite settles but it is attracted into
this comfort zone of about 60
simply because if
a lot of people are forecasting high
numbers
for quite a while
those forecasts won't be validated they
won't show up
if people are forecasting low numbers
for
a long time
um they'll all show up and
and high forecasts would be validated
so there's a kind of tendency to the
middle
i can see why
complexity is arising in this right
you're allowing the different agents to
use different set of strategies and
there's some obvious notion of
complexity there what one of the
interesting things about it though is
you use this to illustrate an issue in
economics and but there's no mention of
money or prices or goods or anything
like that so it lets it makes me wonder
you know how are you even defining the
word economics which presumably is the
easy word in this phrase complexity
economics
[Laughter]
i wish
[Laughter]
yeah
what i i think of the economy as the
set of ongoing arrangements we make i
throw in the word ongoing because
this keeps changing
it's the arrangements and actions we
make
to
try to fulfill our needs so you could
say it's a market it's got goods it's
got prices but
what i just said is much more general
could be barter it could be
robinson cruz living alone it's uh it's
how we organize ourselves to full to try
to fulfill our needs
and that often might mean we might have
a need to hear irish music on a thursday
night
and so this is very much economists
immediately recognize what i just said
as a
an economic problem
there's incentives to do something
but the space in which you're trying to
do it is
a function of what other people are
the way other people are trying to solve
the same problem so the essence of
economics i think is not
um
the essence of economics is not markets
and prices and things being produced in
a real economy that's very important
but the essence of economics is trying
to make decisions
in a situation where other people are
trying to make decisions as well
and for me that's very much complexity
i'll give you an example of that that i
think is totally trivial
you might be on a freeway here in
california
let's say the traffic's quite dense for
some reason a lot of cars packed in
i'm trying to make decisions about my
speed and
the lane i'm using
based upon the traffic
but the traffic consists of other people
trying to make decisions
independently in different cars
in
the traffic and if you look at that
formally
i sometimes use this as an example and i
once shocked audiences i said if you
think about that formally there's no
such thing as traffic
traffic doesn't exist
cars exist
the local cars surrounding you we tend
to call traffic
but it doesn't quite exist so it's
basically
individuals trying to make decisions
in a situation where other individuals
are trying to make decisions
i got a lovely comment after saying that
one time
god i would not like to be in a car if
arthur's driving he doesn't believe in
traffic
no but i like that actually this is
great i've already learned something
because that's the best definition of
economics i've ever heard
we have desires right we have goals we
have incentives and there's a bunch of
agents with different ones and they're
sort of jostling up against each other
and how do they organize that how do
they make things happen so to hopefully
everyone's mutual benefit i suppose
oh well uh
to be very western about it
we would say
would be very economist about it we'd
say to our own benefit
and hopefully hopefully that spreads out
and benefits other people but at the
center of economics at least the center
of what's interesting in economics is
individuals we call them agents
sometimes players sometimes investors
sometimes
consumers and so
individuals trying to make decisions in
a
situation i would call it an ecology
of other people trying to make decisions
uh maybe in the same meal you're the
same
situation
and that's what's interesting because
people's behavior is not predictable
it's not like ions and um
this is maybe not the right jargon ions
and the spin glass
apparently are a lot more predictable
than human beings
donating money to help people is a
wonderful and selfless act but how can
you feel confident that your donations
are improving the most lives you could
do weeks of research to find charities
that are out there what programs they
run how effective they are
or you could visit givewell.org there
you'll get a short vetted list of the
best charities they've found at saving
or improving lives the most per dollar
every time i go to the webpage at
givewell.org i end up donating because
their causes are so good and so
compelling whether it's fighting malaria
giving vaccinations deworming vitamins
or just straight small amounts of cash
to people in poverty to help them get
out of it
if you've never donated to give wells
recommended charities before you can
have your donation matched up to one
thousand dollars before the end of
august or as long as matching funds last
to claim your match go to givewell.org
and picked podcast and sean carroll's
mindscape at checkout make sure they
know that you heard about givewell from
mindscape to get your donation matched
i do like this because it
casts economics in a light where the the
complexity aspects of it are right there
front and center and
i guess therefore for the audience which
might not be trained in ordinary
economics let's let's contrast this uh
there's sort of the standard
neoclassical economic picture which you
contrast with um the complexity
economics picture and i think that you
try to make the argument that standard
economics is a subset of
complexity economics right complexity
economics is not a subset of classical
it's that complexity economics is
letting a lot more freedom into the way
we think about things
yes i think standard economics it's
called neo-classical economics
uh we've had uh
this for the last
150 years or so
albeit in different forms
and the way economics is done let me
back up a bit around the 1870s
it began to seem a good idea to
many economists
in england actually
germany and austria largely france too
and europe
to
think that they could use algebra
and
calculus
to
really look more formally and more
rigorously at problems and economics
and that meant the price of doing that i
think that was successful and we've it's
lasted for quite a long time and will
still continue no doubt
but the price of doing that was
like in
physics which was emulating to quite
some degree you had to make certain
assumptions and the assumptions that
economists came up with to solve
problems
in different settings in economics was
to assume
individual players that were
very often identical
so
that were
rational meaning
they could solve
any
logical
problem
or they could optimize
in any setting so they were supposed to
by assumption be
super bright
that they were well informed they knew
that everybody else was just like them
they knew everybody else's preferences
sometimes you could say well they're a
bit blurred but they know the
probabilities
of how other people would react and so
on so they're well informed
and then the whole thing
is supposed to happen at equilibrium so
let me
give my version of that
um what you're interested in in
economics is how individual behavior
leads to an overall outcome
and of course an overall outcome
would feed back to individual behavior
just like
the cars and traffic
so how how do the individual
agents
together act so that some overall
maybe in the market forms
and we want to look at situations
that are in balance or consistent just
keep the mathematics simple so let's
look for a solution in which everybody's
identical
they're all hyper rational they're
solving an optimization problem maybe
under constraints
and you're looking for an outcome
that causes the individuals not to
need to or want to change so it's a bit
like saying
and
forgive me here for being
slightly
mean about this but it's a bit like
asking how do butterflies fly
and
okay well we'll figure that out by
chloroforming them and nailing them to a
board and examining the wings
i think that
that's
rather extreme to say but we're looking
at consistency in standard economics
what behavior is consistent with the
outcome
it
mutually creates and
in complexity economics
the whole idea is to drop those
assumptions or at least
things didn't come out that way that's
not the way it started but it now
amounts to saying
what if
individuals differ what if they're not
hyper rational
what if they're
not well informed and
what if they're just reacting to the
outcome and the outcome never settles
down and they keep reacting at infinitum
and what would economics look like
so it's not that anybody said we're
looking to have a more general economics
but if you start to say we'll do away
with the assumptions it is more general
so it's like in mathematics you can say
well
i
we're not quite sure we want to include
euclid's fifth axiom here so let's drop
that
and have a non-euclidean geometry and
let's examine that
um
i don't want to make uh complexity
sound any more
difficult or highfalutin than it is but
it's essentially looking at economics
under more realistic conditions
and what you find is the economy
or the system you're looking at starts
to look much less ordered and perfect
and mechanical and much more like
changing ecology
where things change and may never settle
down you know it's funny because there
clearly is some level of parallelism
with physics number one you mentioned
the 1870s uh as the beginning of the
mathematician of economics and
to my mind when you say 1870s i'm
thinking the beginning of statistical
mechanics and boltzmann and maxwell and
thinking of you know thermodynamics
coming out of all these motions of atoms
and using similar techniques but also
the idea of equilibrium versus
non-equilibrium like
to mike chagrin
most thermodynamics and statistical
mechanics over the history of physics
has also been in this equilibrium
context where you sort of imagine that
everything quickly reaches a more or
less steady state and you can
study things then it's only in the last
15 or 20 years that we've really made
important progress in non-equilibrium
statistical mechanics right
um
it's not a coincidence
at all
one of the founders of the field in
those days alfred marshall really
important economist at cambridge
england
was
very highly trained in
mathematical physics i think he was
second wrangler
in
physics
the year he graduated
so
and subsequently between 1870
roughly and
1900s economists
did study
statistical mechanics they
they were studying people
um
like boltzmann and others who had
brought in this point of view and i
wouldn't say they lifted it wholesale
but they thought this was probably a
similarly a very good approach
what i'm finding at the moment is that
people sometimes say to me
is you know aren't you trying to shoe
horn economics into
a new approach
called complexity and i say no not at
all
um
we there's a whole movement in
sciences
away from looking at things totally
mechanistically
uh in some sort of newtonian framework
or
some kind of
statistical mechanics framework
at equilibrium and looking at questions
of how
solutions form over time not how they
persist over time which may not at all
give you
equilibrium in fact almost by definition
it wouldn't
and so we're looking more at formation
we're looking at
how
how things form be they
species or be they whatever galaxies or
larger complexes
in the universe
how do things
change over time will they ever settle
down
and so in some way it's not surprising
that that
emphasis in formation is also coming
into the social sciences economics in
particular
and i think that it's inevitable
one of the questions i've been asking
myself is why have we switched from
looking at
order uh equilibrium
perfection like perfect rationality
why have we switched from that
in general and i think that
certainly with the rise of
molecular biology and genomics
proteomics and other
aspects of biology
we see much more complex
or complicated in this case
we see more complicated
structures that may never
settle down
those structures
evolve
and change and reform depending on what
is already there
so they don't settle down necessarily
even at the molecular level or at a
more
meta
zoological level
they they don't settle down we're
starting to see cosmology i think
much more that way and also i would say
computer sciences come in
and
since the 1950s 60s
uh we're now much more aware that if you
take a method in computation a la
touring now we call them an algorithm
your average algorithm doesn't
necessarily
uh as a dynamic system
uh how something works out in a well
codified series of rules or steps that's
an algorithm um that doesn't necessarily
settle down at all
in fact uh
i like the work of stephen wolfram
uh who shows that very very simple
systems cellular automata in general
don't settle into anything i can easily
predict
the highly ordered and simple ones are
the exceptions
so overall science is starting to see
order and perfection and
equilibrium
more as
fortuitous exceptions
and thank god there is some order
and it's looking to formation and and
accepting the change is constant
in fact we don't have to rule it out
precisely because we have computation
and we can start to track this sort of
thing don't have to
reduce it to algebra on a
on a few sheets of paper so science is
changing
um economics i think is following or
will follow the zeitgeist and change
itself
so as a observer who is not an at all an
expert in economics i'm i'm wondering if
we conjured up here
a uh
establishmentarian neoclassical
economist would they agree with this uh
idea that these represent
shifts away from the neoclassical
paradigm i mean i know that at least in
the realm of allowing
agents to not be perfectly rational
isn't that something where economists
have sort of caught on to that already
yeah the the answer to this i think is a
bit complicated but um
you could have two answers one is
uh you know
nothing new here let's move on
the other answer is yeah there's a
definite shift in
the way we're looking at things so let
me let me speak for both sides i think
in the
standard neoclassical economics with
these uh very stringent conditions that
are there mostly to allows to
mathematize economic
economics problems and
look at them analytically which is
something i would certainly cheer on
that sort of economics
yeah it's been able to relax one
condition here and one condition there
and you're kind of
holding on to the rest
so let's assume for example that people
are not
quite
perfectly informed
but we're still dealing however with
probabilities and will still allow
equilibrium and so on so economics i
would say in that regard yes has relaxed
stringent conditions
here and then possibly somewhere else
and
looked at the strangeness or
interesting things that happen
so i'm not saying any of this is
completely new
things i think in science are rarely
completely new
but
yeah but i think that's um
to go back to a sort of thomas kuhn
version of things yeah if you want to
hold on to the
older way of looking at things
you can
hang on to the cliff edge by your
fingertips and say ah well you just
relaxed two conditions here
it's still neoclassical i don't know
it's like saying
uh
how many conditions do you need to relax
before you're doing economics a
different way
that's fair i just wanted to sort of you
know let the
let the audience know that there would
be the occasional neoclassical
economists who who would raise their
hackles a little bit but the point is
who cares who cares what the label is
you know what matters is what we're
doing scientifically
i wouldn't
set up the question saying what would a
neoclassical economist make of this you
know you could say what
i was around
academia in stanford when
uh molecular biology
was
coming in uh big time in the 70s or
actually in the 80s and
people were it was supposed to be
revolutionizing this and revolutionizing
that and
the people doing molecular biology were
very happy with discovering new things
and the
more standard folks were
really annoyed that funding and so on
was going to this new version of the
field what i'd like to see is
um
all types a wider approach to economics
it doesn't say
any different set of assumptions or
relaxing an assumption is a travesty and
should not be published and should not
be allowed
i've got a different way of looking at
things than sort of saying what would
the old guard make of this
in fact
standard neoclassical economists
don't pay much heed to
non-standard ideas that's in my
experience
they've had to because
there's been a wonderful development in
economics where behavioral economics has
come along saying okay we accept people
aren't infinitely smart what do they do
in reality right and that's now accepted
and then we're saying
equally
that
it's not that
agents or people in the economy are all
alike there might be multiple firms
doing
slightly different things and we can
allow them to have well specified
strategies that may differ and so you
get something like game theory
and eventually after 40 50 years that
was accepted in economics what i find or
actually
a colleague of mine
rob axtell
has found it takes 40 to 50 years
for a new
version of economics to come in game
theory or behavioral economics possibly
this form of economics complexity
economics
it takes uh several decades before
people get comfortable textbooks have to
change and editors have to
loosen their thinking a bit um
so
i think it's a matter of time before
this version of economics which is
saying what if you
have more realistic conditions that
people aren't
solving perfectly well-defined problems
that there's an awful lot of what
economists call fundamental uncertainty
you just don't know how to forecast
fundamentally in the elf or all problem
what you're
trying to do is to explore to cope
to come up with new strategies
and therefore things may always change
so this is
that's way of thinking is new in
economics
it was not that new
200 years ago people did think in these
terms but they couldn't mathematize it
yeah and what has happened i believe and
what's driving this change
you could say it's
a bunch of people at the santa fe
institute or something
what's really driving the change is that
in the
early 1980s we all got computers we
got what we then called desktop
workstations yeah
and that meant that we could set up
models
be there in physics or in cellular
automata or
traffic formation
or indeed in economics where we could
write the rules differently
and relax some of these incredibly tight
constraints
and still track what happens
and when we track what happens we find
things that are much more realistic
so
my commentary in all of this is that
um
from my observation of
science the history of science in
particular history of technology
and economics
whole fields tend to change
when they use different instruments a
classic example is
1610
galileo
develops his own telescope points at a
jupiter
apparently jupiter was going retrograde
at the moment
astrology and astronomy overlapped to
some degree
and
lo and behold
the better resolution meant that
galileo could see
some fixed
stars nobody had seen behind jupiter
and as he looked on the success of
knights
he thought he could measure jupiter's
um
transition against these fixed stars but
amazing the stars were
not so fixed not so fixed
and after about five nights he sort of
says holy
shmoly
i don't know what he would have said in
1610
oh my god
the um
these are moons around jupiter so
classically when new instruments
new methods come in to science
there's a shift in what can be seen
and so when
standard mathematics comes into
economics
uh big time in the
1870s and on
you could see things more exactly more
rigorously
with algebra and calculus just as
you could in physical systems
but now we have computation
and computation is extraordinarily
important
in molecular biology
in
genomics in
astronomy
in physics itself in mathematics
increasingly
and now in economics
it's changing what we can see we can
look at more complicated systems we can
relax assumptions
and this is showing us
a new world
and it's showing us a different world in
a world that's looking far more
ecological and far more
biological and far more realistic if you
ask me
and any field that's done that there's a
lot of skepticism
you know
um galileo if i i wasn't there at the
time but galileo
i believe invited
luminaries up to the top of his house
in the evenings to look at the
moons of jupiter
many of them didn't have decent eyesight
couldn't see it young people could see
it some accepted galileo was right but
many said look this isn't real
astronomy real astronomy is seeing
something with your own eyes how do i
know these little specks aren't part of
your instrument
and we all get moats in our eyes so you
know give me a break you really haven't
discovered anything new here so i think
this is what's happening in economics is
a mixture of
with these new methods with computation
in particular
um
wow
look at this look at that
and on the other side well you know
come on
if you're trying to get smarter you want
to read and listen to the best possible
sources but if you're building a company
you want to hire the best possible
people and to do that indeed is the
source to use when hiring gets hard
indeed is the job site that makes it
incredibly simple you can attract
interview and hire all on the website
and you don't just hope your perfect
candidates will find you indeed's hiring
tools will help you cut through the
noise to hire faster and smarter
indeed instant match provides a list of
quality candidates whose resumes are on
indeed the moment you post a sponsor job
and with indeed assessments you choose
from 135 skills tests to help make sure
you're finding applications from people
with the skills you need
so get started right now with a 75
sponsored job credit to upgrade your job
post at indeed.com
mindscape that's a 75 job credit at
indeed.com mindscape indeed.com
mindscape offer valid through september
30th terms and conditions apply
let me let me just dig in a little bit
more to this non-equilibrium aspect of
things um i mean on the one hand
it wasn't crazy for neoclassical
economists to focus on the equilibrium
case just like it wasn't crazy for
maxwell and boltzmann to focus on
equilibrium uh thermodynamics right i
mean right there are things that are
more or less in equilibrium for a while
but there is in some case in the real
world
in some sense there's a competition of
time scales right you know in physical
systems things equilibrate when the
microscopic uh processes are going on
much faster than the sort of big
macroscopic constraints that that fix
them and presumably an economy uh has
many different time scales many
different layers of organization going
on and they're all sort of talking to
each other
and
so sometimes that equilibrium assumption
or the the
conditions under which that's a good way
of thinking about things break down i
mean can we say anything in general
about when that happens has has
complexity economics taught us something
about that
i would say so i think you're absolutely
right by the way i'm not saying that
complexity economics
uh the way it's done
uh applies to everything in the economy
there are many parts of the economy say
oil markets for example
that reach equilibrium possibly after a
day and a half you know something
happens with opec and then
within
half a day markets have equilibrated and
there's a new price formed and people
have adjusted to that so
certainly in shorter time scales
equilibrium
is
warranted
and i also think that if you're teaching
economics
it's
a really wonderful benchmark
there's a lot of deep thinking behind
equilibrium and economics
that
people's behavior is somehow in
equilibrium or consistent
with
the incentives that are posed
by
the outcome
and i think that's a wonderful insight
and it takes a year or two when you
learn economics before that fully gets
onto your skin
on the other hand i think there are
short-term and long-term situations that
are not subject to equilibrium
i um
i'm trained as an engineer originally
and a mathematician and i was i'd be i
wrote a book in fact spent many years
looking at
the evolution of technology
and
at first i might have said
well new methods come
in steel making
maybe once every decade or two
bessemer process arrives whenever
1875 or thereabouts
the open hearth process or
other processes
thomas process
these arrive
and in between you could say there's
equilibrium
but when i started to get into it i
realized that
new technologies think of
computational technologies
don't change in
bursts that's what we were trained to
think from an equilibrium point of view
they change
if i may use the term
fractally
the technologies are made out of other
technologies that are made out of yet
other technologies and all these are
changing all the time
so the even the digital technologies of
the computer technologies are morphing
and changing
the cloud becomes available
are
really
good photonic transmission becomes
available in the early 90s
suddenly we've satellites and
fiber optic cable all over the place
and so
for technologies themselves
for the structure of the economy
it's changing at all levels all the time
now we could sort of freeze frame it and
say okay you know let's stop it here and
it might be a very old system like
whatever
fishing for lobsters and lobster pots
haven't changed
but in realistic parts of the economy
i'm standing here in silicon valley
at xerox park
and
things change here
by the month or by the week
and new things come along at all levels
not just at an overall level it's not
just that we got erbium doped
photonic amplifiers in 1987
all sorts of small changes incremental
and almost fractal
used metaphorically
are coming in all the time so the
economy is always changing
and that changes the social structure
that
when automobiles came along we got the
suburbs people could drive out of cities
easily daily
social structures change history itself
changes
what we can do changes we can now fly
across the pacific or the atlantic
in just a matter of hours
social arrangements change economic
possibilities change
and all of that if you look at
equilibrium
has to be either frozen
or ruled out of the picture so the
observation i would make on all of that
is that economics equilibrium economics
is wonderful
at looking at the logic of markets and
incentives and
what i call
what economists call questions of
allocation
how many
how many widgets how many grand pianos
are produced
versus how many
computer screens
are produced economics is wonderful at
these questions of allocation of
time or effort or allocation of budgets
and we've had 150 years of mathematizing
that
questions of
where new technologies come from
how they form
how that reforms the economy
how that forms history itself
once we got textile machinery and steam
engines
history in some sense changed and
so those questions
can't be and haven't been looked at
formally
uh simply because
they're not equilibrium questions
and is
one of the sales pitches for complexity
economics is that it gives us a better
understanding of bubbles and crashes
uh because these are inherently out of
equilibrium phenomena i mean
what kind of understanding does it give
us is it not is it we're able to predict
that they will happen or can these
methods of reasoning actually help us
predict when these dramatic phase
transitions occur
i think it's more um and i this would
also apply in physics i think it's more
of the former we can predict that
certain things
will happen
uh we can't usually predict uh when
they'll happen
to go back to my traffic example if cars
are very dense
[Music]
on a highway
and they're moving along but
quite dense then if some small anomaly
happens along the way a dog runs out or
somebody spills coffee
over themselves
then
some car might slow down that might slow
down the ones behind
and suddenly
the slow slowdown or a jam
starts to form now
complexity will show us in general that
that's possible
uh you can theorize about it very often
with equations it's not all computation
and you can do the statistics on it you
but
just like anything statistical you can't
predict exactly when it will happen so
it's like you might know a pandemic is
possible and likely to happen say in
2015
but you don't know exactly when it will
hit and how it will start same in
economics and you know along those lines
um like this is not really a question
but let me make a comment then you can
re-comment on it um the idea that there
are fluctuations is it's a pretty common
one right i mean probably many people
have heard at least they listen to me a
lot that if you have a box of gas and
you just wait long enough
eventually all the atoms for the
molecules and the gas will fluctuate
into one corner of the box or something
like that but
in those kinds of situations where
there's this huge disparity between the
molecular scale and the macroscopic
scale those fluctuations are really
really rare they're very very unlikely
we don't need to worry about that
happening in the room where we're
breathing the air but in these economic
or social situations where you have a
multiplicity of scales and something
interesting happening at every scale
that's exactly when fluctuations become
just inevitable part of your everyday
life is that is that a fair way of
thinking about it
yes i think so um
in fact
the research that brought me into
thinking about the economy as a complex
system was
very much looking at systems that had
positive feedback
we call them increasing returns in
economics as opposed to diminishing
returns
so under standard economics
we very often assume diminishing returns
if oil gets too pricey
in the world market then we will use
maybe
local natural gas or we will switch into
hydroelectric over some time and there's
a balance reached
but
if there's
increasing returns or positive feedbacks
say if in 19 whatever
90 or
20
2001 there's
small firms competing in the search
engine business
alto vista oh yeah
and
a small company called google and so on
if one of those gets ahead
then other people latch on to that and
it's a bit like a language if
there's no reason that english which was
spoken in the 1700s 1500s should now be
a world language but if something gets
ahead it often pays you to go along with
the system that gets ahead so if
something gets ahead by chance it'll
grow and the economy is full of such
systems
and
small events in cases like that
i think in physics you call those
nucleations or something
so these small events
get magnified and form new structures
and it's certainly true that
tech
high technology advanced technology
works that way if enough people are
using say
paypal platform
to pay off their friends or bills
then
somebody else coming along a friend of
mine would want to adopt paypal
versus some other competitor and
suddenly paypal balloons and dominates
the market
economists before we started to
look at
such questions formally economists would
say yeah there are multiple outcomes
but you know
what can you do
there isn't a solution we can agree on
now with this new way of looking at
things and i think this would be true in
physics you just just say oh there's
multiple whatever you call them
metastable states so there's multiple
possible outcomes and those lock in for
a while and then after a while you go to
something else
because some new structure comes along
and i so in that sense there are lots of
phenomena
that are that make sense in this
different form of economics because
we're allowing positive feedbacks not
just negative ones
we're allowing formation
and
we can
and we can examine those actually
not necessarily computationally we can
use
non-linear stochastic
methods
or sarcastic process theory
to look at things like that
it makes me wonder about the you know
one of the very common ideas in complex
systems is
the idea that there's something
happening at all scales uh there are
power laws in the structure of the
system and and so forth
is this too much of a leap or
does this have something to say about
the almost inevitable nature of
inequality in a society like will it be
the case that as long as
economies are complex that there will be
really really rich people and really
really poor people because their
structure at all scales
[Laughter]
yeah
again inequalities a fairly complicated
question there are many answers
anyone any
good economist
could give you
i would say
here i would go back to looking at
positive feedbacks that of one
class of people gets ahead
and they rigged the system to some
degree politically
uh
i i'm
not
saying there's any great conspiracies
but if some class gets ahead then
they can educate their children better
get them off to a better start and
so
it's a
anomalies and inequalities and even we
started off with everything equal in
some perfect society
come about
in the
soviet system changing into
what's now russia in the early 90s
it didn't take very long for
a fairly flat and reasonably
even
distribution i'd just say reasonably of
wealth and income
to turn into what amounted to an
oligopoly and very uneven
set of distributions
so i think that
um
there are inevitably positive feedbacks
that make it difficult
to
have
reasonable equality all over the place
but that doesn't mean we shouldn't try
fair enough okay i just had to get that
out there because i've been wondering
about that myself but in happier news
let me let's switch back to this idea
that uh part of the toolkit in
complexity economics is that agents are
different they have different
information they have different
strategies and so forth um and and
that's actually a
feature in some sense it allows the
economy to evolve in ways that wouldn't
be possible if everyone moved in
lockstep and
i love the id the example that you show
in
one of your papers which we'll link to
in the show notes of this prisoner's
dilemma tournament right
prisoner's dilemma is this famous uh
game theory problem and there's this you
know idea that you have different
algorithms for approaching it and they
compete against each other but
surprisingly to me i don't know how long
i've made it this far in my life without
understanding this but at least in the
example you showed there wasn't an
equilibrium reached it wasn't that there
was a winner and uh eventually you found
it it's that if you just keep running
the tournament different strategies seem
to win at different times
yes i i love that example
it's actually
due to a swedish physicist called
christian
lindgren
working around 1990 so this is not
particularly new
he did a lovely piece of work imagining
that there was a prisoner's dilemma
tournament you don't need to understand
much about
prisoner's dilemma just think of it as
a collection of
strategies that may differ let's say
there's a hundred different
strategies possible
and they compete against each other
one-on-one
repeatedly at random
and
if a strategy
does well it can replicate
it can reproduce itself if it
continually goes badly there's a kind of
trapdoor and it falls out and isn't seen
again
what lindgren did i think was brilliant
uh lovely lovely work he
not only set up this computerized
prisoner's dilemma tournament
but he allowed that
strategies
given strategy say you might be playing
tit for tat
consistently
um
strategies could mutate he had a way of
coding so that
a strategy could mutate into some
neighboring strategy and then he did
something that i thought was profoundly
interesting he said not only can they
mutate but they can randomly deepen
so normally i'm playing this prisoner's
dilemma against similar strategies that
are a bit different
and i'm looking back say one move
and
suddenly i'm faced with a strategy
that's deepened
it's mutated
it can look two moves back two of its
own moves and two of my moves and it's
playing me a hundred times
so
this sort of
history
is good because you can start to figure
out what the other person's strategy is
going to be
and act accordingly
so
what um
lindgren had done was to not just have
mutation of strategies but deepening the
strategies
could notice more
and get smarter
and then he sets all this thing up and
his computer hits the return button and
allows the strategies
to interact and play each other
and he starts from just four simple
strategies that can look back one move
and
lo and behold tit for tat starts to
dominate and some other thing anti tit
for tat
details don't matter but certain
strategies
uh do quite well and what fascinates me
about lindgren's experiment is that you
could stop it at any stage and say oh
the solution's been reached so after
maybe 10 20 000 such
tournaments with these four strategies
one of them dominates replicates
and you can say oh that's the solution
this is the best strategy
but then some strategy deepens
and it enters
randomly and suddenly
everything gets complicated
system goes wild that strategy may or
may not take over but other similar
strategies deepen
and the whole thing gets far more
complicated and goes wild for a while
you know
it's almost like a stock market that
hasn't settled there's
enormous amount of variation
and then things settle down again
and then at some future period things
might deepen again and so on
and you're tempted to say that
strategies at each time you would stop
the whole experiment which might have
taken days on some computer
in sweden
your attempt to stop and say a solution
has been reached
but
a solution i believe is never quite
reached because you can always deepen
further and further and further
and get more and more information more
and more smartness
what this tells me it's a bit like
saying technology keeps changing
you might
you might think well we can
we've got
ships that will transport people in the
1940s 50s across the atlantic and
suddenly the boeing 707 comes along
and the game changes and then many such
aircraft come along
what fascinated me about lindgren's
experiment
was that the strategies
wherever you looked at and formed an
ecology
strategies appeared that were that
mutually fed off each other
as strategy a supports strategy k
which also supports strategy
a
and that dominates for a while
strategies that are parasitic
appear they only work if they can
exploit some other strategy but then
that might die out so they die out
strategies there are times of great
volatility
uh where you see an enormous amount of
change in times of quiescence where
everything looks terribly stable and as
i looked at this
he's got a graph of the outcome over a
quarter of a million
trials or or
such tournaments one leading to the next
when i looked at the graph i thought oh
my god
this reminds me very much of paleo
biology
evolution you know
yes
you have so many species of dinosaurs
this one depends on that one they depend
on dinosaurs that maybe are grazing
which depend on something else so there
are many food webs and there's mutualism
there's competition
there's periods of enormous change
periods of quiescence the whole thing
looked biological yet it was coming out
of an extremely simple
well-defined system
and um
i for me it was a kind of a shocker and
a wake-up call it was done in 1990 it's
a very early version of what we now call
agent-based model
the agents would be the strategies
themselves
we're all trying to get in shape and eat
right and freshly is here to help their
delicious meals are designed by
nutritionists and cooked by chefs making
it easier to eat better freshly offers
chef-made nutrient-packed delicious
meals delivered fresh to your door with
no cooking required we all know that
grocery shopping and cooking can be a
pain especially right now and with
freshly you don't have to your meals
arrive cooked and fresh every week so
you keep your fridge stocked and skip
the trip to the store best of all
ordering is easy you visit freshly.com
and choose from over 30 delicious
satisfying better for you meals like
steak peppercorns sausage baked penne or
their chicken pesto bowl your meals are
always delivered fresh never frozen and
are ready to heat and enjoy in just
three minutes right now freshly is
offering our listeners forty dollars off
your first two orders when you go to
freshly.com
mindscape so stop stressing about dinner
go to freshly.com mindscape for forty
dollars off your first two orders that's
freshly dot com slash mindscape get
forty dollars off your first two orders
the parallel with evolution is very very
clear and very very um provocative in in
some way and it makes me think back
again to this time scale question you
know even if
there were a single best
strategy for the prisoner's dilemma you
can imagine that
the space of possible strategies is so
large just like the space of possible
genomes for a population of species is
so large that
who cares if there is a best one you'll
never find it what you can do is just
spend a long long long time getting
better and better depending on what your
environment is
yeah and if
you might be a very very
smart strategy
and
be faced suddenly
maybe artificially by simple strategies
maybe a
maybe a meteorite it's
it's the computer or something
at the
[Music]
tertiary cretaceous boundary something
changes and then you'll get a different
system
growing up a different system entirely
so i think the biological metaphor is
very good
and i would say in that case
simple very simple setups
which just consist of
given strategies at the start and some
rules for how they might mutate or
change or deepen
can give you not just complicated
outcomes but
ones that appear biological or
zoological
and for me
that is a more organic way to look at
the economy yeah there's an architect uh
wrote
a book in the 1960s robert venturi very
well known
about
complexity in architecture now he didn't
mean complex systems or scientific he
was looking more at
really a reaction to the simplicity of
the bauhaus people yeah the
the order that they wanted to bring in a
luke corbusia and others and he was
rebelling against that
and
he used this
term that i like or two
phrases to sum it all up he said
in architecture recently this isn't a
perfect quote
we we have been subject to prim dreams
of pure order
and i think that that was true and that
came out of a kind of
possibly uh that came out of an
enlightenment view
of what newton had really done these
showed that something quite complicated
certainly in the solar system is
actually
a pure order
if you know you could start with
four equations
inverse law of gravity and all
and
and get something
where the complications suddenly became
ordered
and we began to think in the 1700s that
science is like that should be like that
and we got these
um prim dreams of pure order
what uh
venturi was on about and i love this he
said we need to allow for
things that are
contradictory
things that may even look out of place
things that look more organic and
biological i can't remember the exact
words here
and what we want is to allow
for messy vitality
and so what we're finding and certainly
this is my point of view
we're finding that the world is a lovely
mixture of pure order
and
and
things changing and things changing in a
way that might never repeat and
i like the phrase messy vitality for
that
so i'm cheering economics on if it's
getting out of just purity of pure order
and equilibrium and
perfection
and entering a time
a phase of looking at the economy as
vital
alive changing changing its structure
all the time
with equilibrium
being part of the mix but not
dominating
so this is
an economics of what i would call messy
vitality
one of the things that i really
was struck by uh in your article that i
read was the idea that not only
by starting with these um
agents that we can allow to have
different strategies not only do we
learn how the economy gets put together
the collective behavior gets put
together but we learn about how agents
reason right
we try out different things and we
realize oh that's what they were
thinking all along we never even knew
that
well
there's a lovely move in economics that
i mentioned
a little
behavioral economics and it's basically
showing
um
let me back up in that
in the standard way of thinking if you
think that uh perfect rationality
that all agents
are
in
or facing well to find problems and
solving those perfectly rationally
optimizing and so on then any deviation
from that appears to be
uh
stupidity rationalities bounded they're
just not that smart
the way i would say it is otherwise and
say that
agents
in the economy the players just simply
most of the time don't know
what their rivals will be doing they
they don't know what to do it's a bit
like a year ago a year and a half ago
in march
2020 with a new thing we had a pandemic
and we didn't know how it would work out
how infectious it was what strategies
what mutations were possible and so on
so in the economy most of the time we
don't know there's what economists call
fundamental uncertainty you can't even
put decent probabilities on outcomes you
don't know what
this is true in silicon valley you might
be entering some space we're going to
dominate the space say of
driverless convoys of vehicles in los
angeles or something that might be 10
different companies
trying to do that but you don't know
what the technologies are for the others
or the resources or the regulations
or the insurance procedures and so on
you don't know
and
this is where
standard economics would come to a halt
and say okay problem isn't well defined
therefore optimal behavior is not well
defined
therefore rationality
isn't well defined
in this case
and i remember one very prominent
economist
telling me that
you know he recognized that was very
much
part of the world and he
um he had a nobel prize in economics he
threw up his hands he says i get it he
said i believe the world's like that but
what can you do
and it was in santa fe
that we started to think this was in
1980
when we started this program i was in
charge of and the economy is an evolving
complex system that we began to think
yeah people do make moves in ill-defined
problems they explore
they try different options they cook up
different beliefs they
they they explore different strategies
they explore different means of
forecasting
what if we allowed them to do this at
least on a computer what would come out
and i must say we were very heavily
influenced by the ideas of john holland
who was one of the pioneers of
how do you teach computers to
play decent game of checkers and then
chess
all the way down now to
go and
alphago zero etc there's a lineage of
thinking and basically saying okay we
can try this try that and learn
what works
but other agents are learning too so the
situation keeps changing and there's no
point at which you say you you've
optimized because the situation will
change as other people make new
discoveries yeah it seems to me that the
the lesson from you know the the more
recent experimentations with alphago
uh alpha zero et cetera is just you know
don't try to teach them at all let the
algorithms learn you know they're much
better at it than we are at teaching
them and am i correct do i remember
correctly that somewhere you mentioned
that there was a kind of a phase
transition
uh as a function of how much
experimentation you allowed the
algorithms to do if they were only
allowed to do a little bit they never
found a better solution but if you let
all the algorithms experiment a lot a
whole bunch of new things could happen
yes and
we started to look at
financial markets at
the problem of asset price
asset pricing
what you'd call a theory of the stock
market
and we cooked up there was a
neoclassical solution to that and it
says
um
if
all investors were identical
and operated with a single
company single stock
and that stock gave you
varying random earnings
uh what prices would develop to reflect
those random earnings what would the
stock be worth stock price how would it
move over time looks quite realistic
this beautiful work
done by robert lucas in the late 1970s
that became a kind of standard in
economics what we did was to say well
hang on this was in santa fe
we
are going to set up a stock market in
the computer
this was in 1988
and the investors will be
artificially intelligent computer
programs
so
and they will work by
testing out forecasts and
making bets and figuring out what's
working but they're all doing this and
they're all mutually presumably getting
smarter or at least more experienced
and we'll allow them to do that
exploring of new ideas new strategies
all different of course
among different players will allow them
to do that
at a certain rate so what i would call a
twiddle parameter physicists do this
routinely i notice
uh we called it lambda
if lambda was low meaning they didn't
explore very often then you were
attracted
the whole system then like a bunch of
stars all these different strategies
start to
be attracted towards robert lucas's
standard outcome
and
and the market settles down
and it's like
it's almost as if there's a
gravitational attraction
towards
this
so-called rational expectations
equilibrium
the neoclassical solution
and we saw that and
the computer output showed that
and i was terribly disappointed i
thought something more interesting would
happen
when we turned the parameter up so they
could explore a bit more often
and indeed into a realistic
mode of exploring because we had data on
how humans
changed their minds and so on
we found that there was phase transition
suddenly the standard theory by the way
shows that there there can be no such
thing as a market psychology
why because all agents are identical
there's actually no trading because the
one agent wants to sell
the
all other agents are the same and they
want to sell there's no buyers so the
price adjusts until people are
indifferent
there's no technical trading you can't
look at past
history
and predict in any way there's no
bubbles and crashes
when we turned our knob up a little bit
and allowed people to explore more
realistically often
suddenly all those phenomena appeared
there was a market psychology trivially
technical trading appeared
and it wasn't because people were using
these strategies to say i'm optimizing
they found that worked
in a market where other
artificial agents were doing the same
thing
so we got all these emergent strategies
and lo and behold
that's these are phenomena that rail
markets show
so we were looking for
can we find a problem where our
apparatus our methodology
uh complex systems
comes up with something
that standard um that's in the real
world but uh standard
neoclassical economics can't see
so suddenly our little telescope
it was on a mac plus on my desk uh was
able to show
moons of jupiter that were actually
there i i'm exaggerating here but for me
it was a breakthrough moment we were
we were showing actual phenomena that
are statistically present
in rail markets
and i remember i'd gone back to stanford
then i used to
call the guy in charge of this in santa
fe every two or three days and i'd say
what's the market doing today and he
says oh
it's highly volatile at the moment
somebody's discovered new strategy and
everybody else has to adjust or ah
nothing's happening it's quiet
so
it began to feel like a real market
there's not been a lot of work done on
this
and i think those findings hold
that complexity economics can actually
see
realistic phenomena bubbles and crashes
periods of high volatility and
periods of quiescence that you see in
real markets and for me that was a
breakthrough moment it was remarkable
so okay i have two more questions i'm
just giving you a warning because uh
they're easy questions to ask
but they're very broad so i'm going to
let you choose how in what detail to
answer them um the first one is
is there a worry
that this computational approach like
you just described where you have this
simulation running um
that somehow
if that's the right tool for this
question then we'll never be able to get
an understanding at the deeper level
that we could get with an explicitly
equation analytic based way of thinking
about things like we can study different
systems on a system-by-system basis but
it's harder to find the general laws is
that a true worry
i think it's i wouldn't call it a worry
but it's definitely a concern i don't
want to say computation is the answer to
everything
and a great deal of the early work we
did on what's now called complex systems
in economics uh was equation based and
i i'm very much
trained and user of
nonlinear stochastic process theory so
we did an awful lot of that
but definitely computation is here and
it's here to stay
what i would say is that
when you set up an equation based system
you're basically
setting up how individual agents
usually
behave you're well defining that
there's many assumptions you're making
and you can follow the logic
via
mathematical
deduction from line to line to see how
some outcome
is formed and the outcome itself you can
analyze
analytically as well it's all there in
equation form
but i
it seems uh clear to me that you're not
doing anything terribly different when
you compute you usually start off with a
lot of equations
in the algorithm you set up you design
your algorithm
the equations might differ because each
agent maybe differs
and there's a lot of exploration and
discovery and mutations and finding
uh new things just as there would be in
alphago zero
you're not starting your equation your
agents off with
uh supposed insights you're just
starting them from zero
and watching them get smart
um
is this kind of a hodgepodge
is that just sort of ah we can compute
uh
and then i can twiddle the assumptions
and get something different out
i would say
maybe in the wrong hands uh things can
go like that but i think if you're doing
rigorous honest science you're tracking
your assumptions
versus what it shows you and you're
doing that rigorously
just as
you were in christian lindgren's
setup or on the l for all problem you're
watching how things come out you have a
record a detailed record step by step of
how that came out you can
make arguments greg chaitan does this
that
computational descriptions are every bit
as theoretical as equation based
descriptions
that's a
a side observation i like it and
i've always admired his work this comes
out of algorithmic information theory
and that's an aside
but what you can do is once you see
something oh my god our agents are
getting into little bubbles and crashes
we are seeing periods of high volatility
and low volatility then you can go back
and find
deeper explanations qualitative ones and
test those out isolate the phenomenon
in question
so again if you
said we we have equilibrium flow traffic
and we're not seeing anything but the
equilibrium and we can see how the
traffic forms and so on um yeah
but with um
[Music]
computational system
that's open to
new behaviors you might see traffic jams
forming
once you see traffic jams forming you
can slow that down and ask
how that forms you can refine the models
you can make toy models of that you can
reduce that into simple equations often
and you see this i believe again and
again in physics where
some anomaly appears
and then there's a theory it the anomaly
might appear experimentally
or it might appear computationally or it
might be at the
level of
cosmology or it might be
at the level of
particle physics but you see something
happening
in your experiment and computers are
performing experiments
and then you try to isolate it you look
back through your data how did that form
right so i'm not too worried i think
that
there's an awful lot of very bad
mathematics
in every field
and there's rigorous and beautiful
mathematics
similarly there could be a lot of bad
simulation
but there could be beautifully
formed and beautifully studied in
beautifully analyzed simulation i'm not
against
standard mathematics that's nearly all
my training what i'm
i think it can sit alongside
computation
we used to have geometry in the 1600s
that was mathematics and algebra was
spurned and scoffed at
by kepler and even by newton until quite
late in his
career
and now we have then algebra came in and
suddenly by
1750s that was kosher and
then we began to think that science
meant
reducing things to mathematics and
mathematics was algebra i would say
there's a different form of mathematics
could be rigorous
uh algorithmic mathematics
and we can study that
uh as people like wolfram have done or
greg chaitan and we can look at the
reasons certain
anomalies or outcomes are not even
anomalies certain outcomes can occur
it's very much like the controversy in
the four color problem
that might have been the 70s or early
80s the four color problem if you recall
in
mathematics was solved by computation
standard mathematicians said oh my god
this isn't mathematics where's the
reasoning and so on
the computational people say well we've
settled the problem
and it was as if uh
the astronomers in
1610
many of them were saying astronomy means
looking closely at the heavens
uh maybe with good instruments but not
with these newfangled telescopes
so computer people were saying the
computer gives you a new instrument a
new
telescope
and
i'm on the side of
not thoughtless computation i just think
we have a new instrument right
computation or algorithmic mathematics
we should treat it very carefully very
rigorously and we should know what we're
doing and it stands alongside
earlier
forms of mathematics
as valid as ever but it's allowing us to
see more deeply uh allowing us to see
new things yeah i mean that sounds
perfectly fair and then the last
question which is maybe implicit a
little bit in things you've already said
but the obvious one is what are the
policy implications of this way of
thinking i mean do you have a way of
[Music]
summarizing for people who are out there
pulling levers on our economy how
thinking about complexity is going to
help them out
well if you
yes i would say that uh
what you can think of is something that
economists now routinely call policy
labs
you can
take for example
just
excuse me
to give a recent example
uh
we are faced with a pandemic
and
as recently as maybe three four months
ago we were wondering if
different
types of vaccines come along who should
they be distributed to and why yeah so
standard economics or standard decision
thinking would make that somewhat
difficult to solve
in a conventional way not totally
difficult
uh set up equations and so on but what
people were able to do was to
put questions like that on a computer
and if it was done carefully you could
get good answers you were basically
setting up what john holland would have
called a flight simulator for the mind
you were saying okay the obvious thing
would be to give vaccines to old people
and they won't
you know if the vaccines are effective
they won't die
but that was just obvious
more subtle uh approach would be to say
let's
give vaccines to younger people the ones
who are out partying
drinking in bars and so on
and
that might cut the transmission weigh
down so that eventually old people will
benefit of course you want a combination
of both but what we can do for policy is
to set up detailed models possibly
computationally
in an experimental lab
and really start to understand the
system vary this very that until you get
really good intuition
learn what you can from the real world
and make your models accurate
i want to add one other thing about
policy that fascinated me
if you assume
any outcome is at equilibrium
that implies
that there's no group of people no
agents who can
game the system or exploit it to their
advantage
and
why if if they could
in an equilibrium economics
they would
already have done that
and so
the system wouldn't be at equilibrium if
someone can come in make a change or
would want to make a change
with if we relax this equilibrium
assumption
we might say something like oh
russia's going to
make its
uh make capital markets free
the year is 1990
you could assume it's going to find a
conventional equilibrium quickly but we
could all
also
make the assumption there might be
coteries of players small groups
who exploit the system to their own
advantage which is exactly what happened
and you can see this again and again so
i think with this if you drop the idea
of equilibrium then you're open to the
view that
uh systems can be exploited or gamed and
we're always surprised when that happens
under this new way of thinking we
shouldn't be surprised in fact we can
possibly anticipate how
that might happen it's a bit like saying
the u.s navy has a very good code
encryption system
it's wonderful and it's not going to be
broken
and that would be the equilibrium
standard
we could also say
uh
we are we have a new encryption system
for the us navy we're going to invite
people to try to break it
and i think that's a very different
outlook
and
when you assume uh equilibrium you're
basically assuming the system
nobody can beat the system
and that's patently untrue
it's a good lesson it's a good lesson
that i think we're getting over a few of
our recent podcast episodes here that we
need to complexify our world view and
the way that we think about things and
that's true whether we're in policy or
just trying to be abstractly thinking
about how the world works so you pushed
us in that direction very effectively
thanks so much brian arthur for being on
the mindscape podcast
and i am delighted and thank you as well
sean
[Music]
you